oh
mais qu'est ce que vous avez à klaxonner
comme ça je suis prête
avenue de chabannes à courbevoie
traverser tout paris vous êtes au
courant si c'était à côté je ne vous
aurais pas appelé c'est là je veux me
donne est simple 80
charmeur
g92 les médecins pensent que c'est mieux
pour moi que je sois dans un
établissement à temps
[Musique]
vous en verrez pas qu'on fasse un petit
détour par vincennes cependant je sais
je sais j'aimerais revoir mon ancien
quartier
oger
le premier homme que j'embrassais scène
matt j'étais en septembre 44
toute façon un éclair
76 ans après j'ai toujours le goût de
ses baisers sur mes lèvres
ça fait 30 ans que j'ai pas fumer
aujourd'hui c'est spécial vous savez ce
que mon père me disait chaque colère est
à coup de vieux
[Musique]
chaque sourire est un peu le jeu
je veux que vous sachiez que ce voyage
en taxi
[Musique]
blues
a été une belle course
[Musique]
ça vous dit allez vous taper la cloche
oh oui oh tout compte fait en avant une
bonne heure voir demain comment non non
non non non non non non vous présenter